my guess is you've never heard of the
wild and the truth is very few people
have it wasn't a critical hit it wasn't
an audience hit it wasn't a financial
hit so it disappeared pretty fast and
nobody ever talks about or even
remembers it let's be honest yeah I can
kind of see why but on the other hand
there's some really good funny stuff in
this yeah I know that sounds crazy
especially considering how the other
half of this stuff is not so great in
fact it's kind of obnoxiously annoying
but good Lauren not only some of the
comedy in this funny but it's inventive
I mean there's some real out-of-the-box
jokes in this movie I think they deserve
to sort of be acknowledged the premise a
lion and his cub live in a New York Zoo
the cub is feeling envious because he
doesn't match the bravery and the
stories of his father so he decides to
run away and try to find his own
adventure leaving the father played by
Kiefer Sutherland and a band of misfits
to go after him to see if they can get
him back these misfits include a koala
played by Eddie Izzard a giraffe played
by Janeane Garofalo a squirrel who's
totally in love with her and a not very
bright snake so yeah on the surface this
sounds like a very Nothing kind of story
and maybe that's why a lot of people
didn't see it well okay I have to be as
that's not the only reason lines like
this or why dude
yes that is stupid but on the other hand
they come across some really inventive
stuff in this bill like a group of
undercover geckos whose camouflage is
beyond impressive a religion of
wildebeests who think a koala toy that
fell from the sky is God and probably
the only enjoyable game of sweeping
you'll ever see in your entire life I
like the characters in this movie like I
said they don't always get a laugh but I
do enjoy their interactions off each
other and you do feel sort of this
comradery they're enjoyable to watch and
every single time a groaner joke would
come up I would tell myself you know
what I still want to keep going and for
every bad joke there is in this movie
there's always a good joke I was made to
nibble and be elegant and to appear in
children's books as the letter G I'm not
good enough read or hear something no
it's just I'm allergic to nuts don't
panic I'm in charge here that's why
we're panicking that settles it then
my mother definitely drank pool water
when she was pregnant with me I think my
favorite just for surreal miss has to be
this one ah that is such a strange line
how can you not laugh at it
I'm usually not one for villains in
these movies either but the backstory
they give this villain and his cult is
just so much fun and it's so inventive
and it's always constantly funny even
the side villain played by Patrick
Warburton he's pretty enjoyable and he
better not screw this up like just
screwed up I danced I lost gal for one
verse step pivot kick walk walk walk
gah why do we even bother rehearsing so
I'm kind of torn on this I mean on the
one hand it is pretty annoying and some
of these jokes really are painful but on
the other hand if I didn't sit through I
never would have gotten to the really
funny jokes or these characters or these
really inventive situations so kind of
half and half but honestly I'd say go
see it I think everybody will find at
least one or two jokes that would make
them say it was worth the price of
admission for me personally I found a
lot more including some creative
characters and creative setups I mean
much more effort was put into these
jokes than say Chicken Little or cartoon
and those are no more than this film
give it some credit and at least watch
it judge for yourself it deserves the
option to be known about by no means
flawless in fact in reality it probably
has too many flaws but the stuff that's
good I'm really glad I saw and
surprisingly I may even check it out
again in the future take it for what
it's worth find out for yourself
you